haven't made those New Year's plans yet
it is time to get going and you can do
it at click bar and lounge and joining
me now is their lead mixologist with the
coolest name ever Tony arnoni to tell us
more welcome Tony Hi how are you doing
Mercedes we are so happy to have you
here getting ready for New Year's right
around the corner and click has some
really cool things going on tell us
about what's happening there so for a
New Year's Eve weekend we're actually
going to be open up early every single
day to kind of Usher in all these new
sporting events we'll be showing on uh
one of our you know 10 HD TVs we're also
going to be having New Year's Day our
featured breakfast menu which is amazing
featuring the signature amazing Bloody
Mary's that I'm going to make for you
today and so many people will start
their days a little early
and maybe some of the drinking and yeah
Bloody Mary is a perfect way to start it
so show us how to make the perfect
Bloody Mary okay so this is one of our
spins here click Lounge it's called The
Blood Sweat and Tears okay first you're
going to start off with your standard
highball glass
take the Slime oh you're right here this
is why you're a mixologist something
like that there's a whole method to this
so we're going to add this nice tahin
which is this beautiful chili salt to
add nice little spice okay
that's right and where is Quick uh for
everyone that wants to check it out it's
going to be located in the center of the
Cosmopolitan Hotel you can't miss it
there's a beautiful Lounge
oh here we go we'll take our casamigos
tequila that that's a good tequila
highly recommended
I love your so you're not only about
making a good drink but it's really
about the aesthetic of the drink and
making it look beautiful too that makes
the whole experience so great 100 you
know there's a lot of places you can get
a bloody mary but there's only one place
to get our Bloody Mary yes and the best
Bloody Mary so so what's this so this is
in chair areas it is a chili liqueur
kind of gives it this nice little bitter
spice element to it can I smell that one
of course you can of course I've never
heard of a chili liqueur before yes of
course oh we're gonna add a little bit
of habanero bitters here for a little
bit of kick okay this is going to be
spicy it's going to have a little bit of
kick to it so yeah yeah and then we're
gonna do our house recipe this is a kind
of a secret blend of uh bloody Mary mix
here that really is beautiful
okay and the garnish yes no Bloody Mary
will be complete without some beautiful
strips of bacon here because why just
drink your cocktail eat it and drink it
almost beautiful beautiful serrano
pepper here I'm going to top it with
chili salts watermelon and pineapple
juice that is truly a work of art wow
and so you can get these a quick and
again you guys are opening early tell
everybody one more time about some of
the hours and the specials you have
going on so we're opening up early every
single day for um New Year's week New
Year's Eve weekend then on New Year's
Eve itself we're at 9am or 9 p.m we are
doing a open bar package for more
information just visit click lounge.com
for reservations and things like that
then we're also doing our breakfast uh
menu which includes our signature Bloody
Mary's breakfast bowls and burritos what
kind of you're talking about the the
food I mean I I don't want to skip
across that the breakfast bowls you have
like a lot of good stuff there yeah of
course of course they just have a wide
variety of different things for all
different kinds of pallets including our
signature Bloody Marys that pair with
the meals you should start 100 here we
go for New Years I mean why not let's
bring in the New Year cheers make sure
you get some of that nice chili salt on
the edge too go go check out quick bar
at the cosmopolitude and see Tony no
need